good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Thursday
congratulations on making it to the
latter half of the week it's a great day
happy Thursday everyone yippee hey hey
who's that who's that girl
hey Jax hey turdy swear to laredy what's
going on nothing much my swirly girly
twirly how swirly are you feeling today
a little swirly a little swirly did you
have a nice evening I did you know what
I wanted to tell you so Taylor
strucker's birthday was last night and
her wife threw her like a really
Queen like birthday event and I think
like you should adopt it for your next
birthday it was so you tell me about it
so maybe not all parts of it so we got
there because you're not I don't think
you're like the first part but we got
there and we did like cocktail hour they
have like a really great apartment like
nice fireplace it was not big it was
like really close friends and family
um and she had her favorite magician
come and like do lit and that magician
like Mentalist
um do like cool tricks on everyone and
everyone was like gagged like screaming
while the in the Kitchen Two Chefs
prepared this beautiful meal
um so maybe I know I know you're not
like into like Mentalist magician things
but like it was a good like I don't know
it was fun like kept cocktail hour fresh
Mentalist greater than magician I will
say but no I don't like things I know
but I do think he would have been
impressed with this guy I had met him
once before he was at Brian's baby
shower his name is Phil and he'll have
you know he'll take two people in the
room who like do not know each other
he'll ask one of them
um
think of the name of like a friend's pet
like something so Random something
nobody in the in the room would know and
through asking various questions he
would figure out the name of the pet
and then also at the same time so it was
Taylor's brother
who thought of like his childhood's
friends
pet and then he asked Bo stasi's husband
these two people do not know each other
like personally and he was like look up
any celebrity on Wikipedia like yada
yada and he gave him like a certain
criteria based on some of the things he
had read from Taylor's brother whatever
the dog's name was Calvin Beau had
selected Calvin Klein
whoa yeah it was like really kind of
spooky it wasn't even so much magic it
was like it was cool yeah no mentalism
is cool and mentalism is cool and then
we just sat down for dinner they had
like this really beautiful long table
set up in their apartment with like
candelabras and flowers and there were
candles all over the apartment and we
got to served this like hella fancy meal
caviar Seafood Towers hella fancy
Tomahawk steaks and Taylor went out of
her way to get Kosher meat delivered
from Park East for me Ben and Margo
which was wow so nice because like all
of our friends now we're kosher and like
whenever we do meals or so it's like a
substitute you know like a vegetarian or
a fish which is great but to get to eat
the same stuff as everyone else oh my
God it was it was overwhelming and they
had like a bartender it was like really
everyone got dressed up it was like
really elevated I was thinking I'm like
this is what Jackie needs to do for her
next birthday okay so I will do that for
my 31st yo come on down 100 I can have
everyone stay with me yeah you could
have like you know a jazz Trio in your
foyer or something that's Trio that's
what I need
you know you have a house we could eat
it outside like yeah it was really it
was like a gorgeous event it's really
Gorgeous I'll start making arrangements
thanks for the idea yeah and like the
long tablescape filled with like and she
like had said something she made like a
little speech she was like so happy like
people from all different walks of her
life being together it was like really
nice it kind of felt like a rehearsal
dinner
nice yeah just an idea throwing it out
there 31st appreciate it what are you
gonna do for your birthday turdy oh you
know me I I have this very complicated
push-up why don't you do that for your
birthday yeah actually maybe
you have a nice Terrace in your building
yeah
I wonder if they'd let me if you ask in
advance enough which like now is in
advance yeah no I mean I can't start
like my birthday is one of the the worst
and best days of the year you know
that's so turdy no I think a lot of
people relate to that I don't think
that's a turdy exclusive
okay
wow the Judgment in the pause I was just
gonna say something else I was just
gonna take me on tangent and like okay
period I'm not gonna
conflict with you turdy I'm not gonna do
it you're not but you love to
um no I'm not I'm I'm not gonna do it
I'm gonna you know sometimes like you
don't have to say everything
that's something I definitely have
learned as I've gotten older and I'm
still working on it for sure but whether
it comes to like a conversation with
human beings or something on the
Internet or just like something I want
to post
you don't you don't have to say
everything yeah so that's how I feel
right now like you know what turdy Walk
In Your Truth
oh that's like you calling me delusional
okay no no that's me having watched the
rest of the Kelsey ballerini interview
and towards the end there was a lot of
that I have to remain true to my journey
like her career it's like girl you're a
success like just say that you know yeah
totally totally and she's walking in her
truth and I'm walking in turdy's truth
today
okay
that's such a good song yeah so let's
see what turdy's truth brings us today
well turkey's truth yesterday brought
her a flight to Vegas I wanted to update
everyone I got an aisle seat
um it's all the way in the back I'm not
thrilled I'm not thrilled but
I gotta see it so I'll just I gotta take
like a Klonopin or something I gotta go
get a prescription for something strong
you have a Xanax laying around a little
I don't know Xanax one of Theos perhaps
I don't have his Rogue Xanax lying
around you wouldn't know what to do on a
Klonopin turdy you've talked so big game
but you're so paranoid using turdy's
gonna be in the back row alone on a
flight taking a narcotic for the first
time
no you're right you call me out hard and
I agree like that's not that's not even
remotely she'll be taking a half of a
half of Theo Xanax no I'll literally be
taking like a half of a half of Benadryl
and being like it's not working
um but I am excited to fly Delta this is
the first time I'm flying Delta since my
special is available on the uh in flight
entertainment so that I'm really excited
to say I wish I was seeing it from you
know a Delta Comfort seat or a first
class seat but it's okay I'm excited
yeah if the special's any good you'll
forget where you are you'll be
transported I could watch it over and
over and next thing I know I'm in Las
Vegas right and I didn't even notice
that I'm smushed
Las Vegas
I love Vegas so much it's just like so
sexy I told you a number of times like I
would you know what it's sad because I
told you a number of times I wanted to
come on your trip with you yeah and you
just like
we're like yeah cool sure I was like I
said yeah the Deeds you didn't send me
anything like I could have been there
to be there like you weren't actually
gonna come ask a follow-up question
uh when are you flying Saturday
why not Friday
it's like a really long story that's
what I'm talking about that's what I'm
talking about like I just felt Uninvited
honestly
oh my God victim mentality okay Morgan
Evan Uninvited oh we're gonna talk about
Morgan Evans today because the wheels of
this story just keep on turning now
don't say turdy they do so we also we
have a great show because there is some
news a little extension from yesterday
the Kelsey stuff but then also to pick
up where we left off yesterday uh we
didn't have time yesterday for deer
toasters and I had three really good
submissions picked out
um so we're doing it today so we can
really dive in help the girls the girls
need help yeah and I'm excited I [__]
love deer toasters yeah I'm excited too
and we have some really good stories
that I think are going to spark
interesting dialogue so without further
uh
the fast five stories that are going to
spark interesting dialogue that you need
to know
am I ready for these stories sure
these stories are brought to you
by modern fertility for a lot of us the
start of the New Year feels like the
right time to schedule doctor's
appointments and check in with where
you're at health-wise but what about
your reproductive Health if you've
always been a planet fan of a fan of
planning ahead like us
figuring out
um your plan for kids is super important
and that's why modern fertility was
created it's an easy and affordable way
to test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple finger prick mail it in
with a prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within six business
days you'll get insight into your
hormone levels like your ovarian reserve
which is basically how many more or
fewer eggs you have um than the average
woman your age and you'll get other
important Health factors that can impact
your fertility the results go deep into
what every hormone means and you can
also download the results to review with
your doctor for next steps
traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars sometimes more but
modern fertility tests are the same
general set of hormones for only 179
dollars plus if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you can get 20
off your test plus you can get
reimbursed for the test through your FSA
or your HSA so if you want kids today
tomorrow or maybe one day in the future
clinically sound information about your
body can help you make the decision
that's right for you and again right now
modern fertility is offering our
listeners 20 off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that means
that your test will cost a hundred and
fifty nine dollars which is a fraction
of what it would cost at a fertility
clinic get twenty dollars off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that's
modernfertility.com toast today's
episode is also sponsored by kitch 2023
is the year of good feel good do good
and be good to yourself kitchen makes
feeling good simple with luxurious game
changing Essentials that beauty
enthusiasts swear by because Hair Care
is the new skin care so whatever your
budget whatever your skill can type n
whatever your hair type Kitsch believes
you deserve little indulgences at
affordable prices started in 2010 by
selling hair ties door-to-door just a
hustle and a dream Kitsch is a
self-funded female founded and now
carried in over 20 000 retail locations
brand their best sellers include satin
pillowcases satin caps and eye masks so
the satin is vegan and cruelty free they
are so good for your hair and your skin
while you sleep if you wake up with A
Rat's Nest and you're like I wonder why
I switched to a satin pillowcase for my
smelly pillow it's from Kitsch and it
has changed I actually did not even go
over my hair with a curling iron this
morning because I usually like before my
satin pillowcase I had to do a fresh new
curling iron blowout look every morning
for the toast not today thanks satin
pillowcase because I really didn't have
the energy they also offer
um heatless satin curling rollers so I
bought these before kids was a sponsor
because I was influenced on Tick Tock
you don't want if you don't want to keep
damaging your hair with heat
um use the heatless satin curling
rollers they're a fraction of the cost
of like a curler uh they're 18 and they
really really work right now now kitch
is offering you 30 off your entire order
at mykitch.com toast that's right thirty
percent off anything and everything at
my kitchen
toast again that's mykitch.com toast for
30 off your order start taking care of
your hair and catch is a brand you could
trust like as simple as that wench as
simple as that as simple as that wench
thank you so much turkey I just wanted
to pull something up because it's put
your main to the first story which is
about the big story of the week more
news coming out page six reported
yesterday that Kelsey ballerini
allegedly cheated on Morgan Evans with
Drew Taggart from The Chainsmokers while
Kelsey ballerini and Morgan evans's
divorce has resulted in a he said she
said situation page six can exclusively
reveal what allegedly happened before
the former couple's marriage fell apart
an Insider claims to page six at the
country pop songs cheated on her now
ex-husband with The Chainsmokers member
Drew Taggart into August 2019 at
Lollapalooza after having collaborated
on their hit 2018's track this feeling
but page six says that Kelsey didn't
come clean about it to Morgan until
2021.
like that [__] that makes no [__]
sense we're told the alleged shift air
combined with other issues led to Kelsey
Calling it Quits with Morgan last summer
and quote blindsiding him with her
decision nobody's reps have returned
comment okay I have many thoughts the
first is
I don't believe this for a multitude of
reasons one the timing is so suspicious
like and I feel like Morgan I don't know
if he necessarily planted this but like
oh it comes out right after call her
daddy like okay two that other part
about it happening in 2018 and her not
coming clean till 2021 let's say for
real she had like an affair or just
cheated one time and they got divorced
in 2021 or like the better no sorry they
got divorced in 2022 in August so like
six months prior look why would you come
clean at that point like the marriage is
already it's clearly ending so like
what's the point maybe to like show that
how checked like he didn't even know I
don't know I have so many thoughts I
don't know what I believe I really don't
but I I feel like I I've been having a
few internal arguments with myself first
of course when this dropped your initial
inclination is like Morgan's team
dropped it yeah but I don't know if I
believe that because I don't know if
Morgan's team would go to page six like
he's from Australia page six is a very
National if not local publication like I
feel like he would have gone to TMZ or
the Daily Mail just something like I I
feel like people in Nashville don't
really put much stock in page six it
gets really like a New York socialite
like yeah like
I I just don't think that's where he
would go so I'm like uh I don't know if
it was him also there was a dumwa blind
a while ago about this rumor that now
Dumas has revealed is the truth
I I'm inclined to believe that it's not
true because that would make Kelsey like
an actual psychopath yeah for doing an
interview about the truth of their
marriage not sparing one detail when she
missed a whole part of the story and I
don't think she's a psychopath I do not
agreed I think the dumwa thing it makes
me less inclined to believe it honestly
I kind of agree with that and also I
feel like there's a chance that and
someone wrote this in the toast after
dark that she had said that they went on
breaks that they separated yeah and
there's a chance that during one of
their separations who knows what the
rules were that she hooked up with Drew
but that she wasn't cheating on Morgan
like maybe Morgan hooked up with someone
and like they were separated and they it
wasn't an affair because the rules were
established that's an amazing call like
everything you just said like I wish
those were my thoughts when I first
started speaking like you're everything
you said is 100 right and again like
you're you're right if let's say this
was true she had long-standing Affair
and then she was out here doing
interviews and writing EPS like it's
such a crazy thing and let me tell you
something not to brag like I know Kelsea
ballerini I've actually known her for
years we're good friends she ain't
[__] crazy you know no that would be
truly psychotic especially because she
doesn't owe us the truth of her marriage
but she sat down and told us the truth
of her marriage down to like you know
the night she slept on the couch like if
an affair was part of the dissolution of
the marriage that would be something to
mention and by the way you know when
Morgan Evans was out here writing that
song that started this whole thing I
feel like if there was this big Affair
and he had known about it there would
have been some sort of allusion to that
like some reference something yeah but I
think that perhaps if it if sometimes
where there's smoke there's fires like
maybe a part of this is true but
everybody is speaking it's the truth it
is true that Kelsey say for example
hypothetical I don't know what I believe
yet it is true that Kelsey and Drew
hooked up it is true that she did not
cheat on Morgan it is true that this
affair had literally nothing to do with
the end of their marriage because it was
a time of Separation where they would
have been separated anyway what everyone
choose to do at that time is what they
choose to do at that time but I would
say it's all of that is true it would
have been worth mentioning on the show
during our times of Separation I
actually connected with other people
which showed me what I could be having
with someone else yeah or none of it's
true
or none of it's true it's like such an
obvious like thing you know like they
had a song together you know what I mean
like okay they had a song together you
could do a song with someone and never
even meet them like for real so that
doesn't mean you're spending late nights
for sure they got they did get a little
specific Lollapalooza August they're
giving us time and place
it's an uninspired rumor I stand with
Kelsey hashtag I stand with Kelsey so
you don't believe this
no no I really don't
I'm I'm inclined not to believe it
on its face either and I don't even
think that's just my bias I think it's
like really
I don't believe it
and again honestly the second that was
like do Moi blinded reveal I'm like oh
okay it's yeah like it could have been
the same person who sent this to dumwa
who told it to Page Six and that person
could be a liar right and that person
could have like ulterior motives yeah
or thinks they know something that they
don't know right so I'm I'm not I'm not
living for this I'm not believing it and
I do not think Kelsey is psychotic
enough to do that no that's like
diabolical Behavior
and I don't think I know that that's not
what we witnessed honestly no I agree
like she was really like emotional
during the interview there was like
tears she laughed hides lows like that
was a real human being like going
through that was not like a something a
serial killer would do
totally agree I like I just I'm not I'm
not believing it okay so that's where
we'll stand on this yeah I wonder if
anybody will
speak that out like I wonder if Drew's
like the [__] you know I feel like
Drew's like always getting dragged into
like these random PR things he's just
like kind of like an obvious choice yeah
like the Selena stuff like how do I feel
like
I feel like he kind of likes it
especially I think The Chainsmokers are
about to have like a major comeback they
did take some time off so I think any
press for a chain smoker right now is
good press especially this is harmless
you know for him it's like yeah party
boy yeah with a married girl like it's
not damaging because it's very much a
part of their brand so I don't think
he's mad but it's just like for me it's
like I don't know why I was like
obviously Drew like I just feel like
that's his shtick yeah
I agree and but honestly there's no one
who could like come out and deny it that
I that would even like change how murky
I feel about it unless Morgan said it's
not true right right you know yeah but
Morgan is like very slowly becoming the
villain in the story because Kelsey's
album is so popular and that interview
was just really it was
I think people felt a lot of empathy for
her okay so she's she's coming out the
hero yes and I just want to read this um
hot take from toast after dark of our
patreon Facebook group because someone
made a really interesting point that
made me see the whole thing like a
little differently and it's just worth
mentioning she is from Alexander she
said this is a hot take it's funny
because I don't really have a side I
agree with Claudia and Jackie that in
divorce in divorce both sides are each
of both sides are to each other equally
the villain but I definitely was leaning
more towards Kelsey the more I think
about it though if the roles were
reversed in this situation I think
people would be responding totally
different like if Kelsey was the less
successful one wrote a song about the
breakup of the relationship and then
Morgan the big star in turn wrote an EP
made a music video and then did a deep
dive interview on the private details of
their relationship no one would be
celebrating Morgan like they are Kelsey
that is fair but you know and they would
be praising Kelsey for getting half the
house
yes no you're a hundred percent right
but that's why and I feel like I've kind
of been very clear about this from the
beginning like I
I'm not a feminist like yeah it's
different because she's a woman and you
know what we are different for men and
you know what I'm okay with that like I
yeah you're right it would be different
but I'm not an equal opportunist right
so I'm okay with this but how are the
equal opportunists feminists wearing
this how does it feels like why are they
upset that he got half the house like if
if it was the woman like and she got
half the house not even half of his big
lucrative career I'd be like okay
yeah no you're right if it was opposite
I would like yeah Kelsey deserves more
but it's not opposite and women are
different and we are not the same and it
is different like ew you're gonna take
money from a woman like yikes like we're
different you know what and I'm okay
with that like let's stop pretending
okay
anyways I thought that was interesting
no it's a conversation definitely worth
having
but I also don't find Morgan to be a
villain in this situation at all me
neither are but for people who don't
know this know him prior and like this
is their first introduction I think for
a lot of people they're just not taking
his side
yeah I'm not taking a side like I don't
think there's a side to be taken like
really nothing crazy happened yeah
really nothing crazy happened everyone
they just grew apart they didn't have
enough to keep them wanting to fight for
this relationship and at the end of the
day
she didn't know if she wanted kids
anymore like that could happen in any
relationship where two people get
married they want a family and then
seven years go by and like if the woman
is like I don't know that changes a
relationship of course
done period no that doesn't even matter
about the CMAs and the couch at that
point no you're right like it's not
really about sides it's not hearing
everyone out not for me it's honestly
just about The Human Experience for me
and about the nature of relationships
but then also sprinkled with a little
bit how success and Hollywood and fame
could impact those things yes for sure
that's to me it's just all about the
human experiment called life
Jackie that's beautiful thank you
turdylicious you're welcome next up
little me actually we have two Mean
Girls drama stories today like the movie
or like girls being mean both
oh is this Kylie Selena Kylie Selena
Haley they're all in it Kylie Jenner
denies silly rumored that she and hilly
Bieber just dissed Selena's eyebrows
Kylie Jenner is setting the record
straight on speculation that she and
Haley shaded Selena's eyebrows the star
Kylie called the rumor silly in a tick
tock comment on Wednesday she said this
is reaching no shade towards Selena ever
and I didn't see her eyebrows post you
guys are making something out of nothing
so Kylie posted a series of Instagram
stories yesterday like close up of her
eyes and eyebrows one picture is like a
little funky she goes this was an
accident then we get Haley's eyes and
eyebrows and then it turns out that
actually Selena had posted something
um of her really overly laminated
eyebrows saying like oops I overly
laminated my eyebrows so people thought
like Kylie and Haley's videos after that
were like mocking like Selena's new
crazy eyebrows but I didn't even think
Selena's eyebrows look that bad the the
way these three tick tocks had
absolutely nothing to do with each other
not Kylie's Haley's not Kylie's to
Selena's
um and
honestly here's what I've learned
because this is like the second time
this week we're even talking about this
because
a few days ago people thought one of
Haley's tick tocks was a reference to
Selena's uh getting body shamed and then
totally separately Haley had used a tick
tock sound that's like I'm not saying
she deserved it but God's timing is
always right but she's just like a funny
cute sound that's gone viral there's
like over a million uses of that sound
had nothing to do with Salida Selena's
fans thought it was like you know Haley
commenting on you know Selena deserved
to get body shamed and then Selena
commented like oh it's okay I don't let
stuff get me down like kind of agreeing
Urban Evans victim mentality and now I
think because Selena commented that on
that old that thing last week her fans
are looking for more stuff to see like
people coming for Selena so in a way
like I do feel like Selena definitely
fed the the fan flamed fan the Flames of
her fandom
last week and now that's why they're
coming for Kylie and Haley again and no
one was coming for anyone not one of
these things is actually like a
legitimate reference to anything Selena
has done and honestly this is just like
the toxicity of fan bases getting out of
control again
yeah also like Kylie's been posting a
lot of stuff of close-ups of her eyes I
think she's coming out with a mascara so
yeah they're doing a Kylie Cosmetics
like relaunch I think that all the
photos Were Meant to highlight eyelashes
not eyebrows and she's in front of her
pink screen I think she's doing like a
video with Haley
I don't even know I'm not I can't even
trying to understand what they're trying
to do but like she runs a makeup company
I wonder if Kylie and Selena like
obviously Kylie's friends with Haley so
she's team Haley but like Kylie and Cena
have their own little beef about like
who's the number one Beauty Guru in this
group so I actually not until five
seconds ago uh thought about that too
like that they both have these competing
really successful like billion dollar
makeup brands I actually don't think
they compete in the sense that like
they're actually really different dirty
they compete if an alien came down to
earth they would say these two things
are the same I know but the way we
didn't even think about the competition
of their brands until right now I feel
like really highlights how different
they are I feel like all the time when
we talk about how Kylie Cosmetics is out
and rare beauty is in like we always
talk about that but let me just say in
terms of like actual competition rare
beauty is a Sephora exclusive brand
Kylie Cosmetics does not even sell at
Sephora they sell like everywhere else
direct to Consumer Ulta
um it's also I think like a little bit
of a lower price point and like
aesthetically like
rare beauty is very like glowy dewy
natural clean girl and Kyla Cosmetics is
very like
colorful color pop almost like
more out there than like that subdued
honestly it's more dated in the sense
like that's what makeup used to be the
crazy color palettes and and now
everything is like neutral and sad beige
and that's very rare Beauty yeah but at
the end of the day like if I want to do
my face full of makeup I can get the
products from rare beauty or Kylie
cosmetics and I'll pretty much look the
same it's just about how they package
themselves like Kylie's very much like
glam makeup Instagram makeup rare
Beauties like you're beautiful the way
that you are but here's a little makeup
yeah when I say if you could do a full
face of rare beauty or a full face of
Kylie Cosmetics what would you do
I think Kylie because I like a little
more coverage okay I like 100 would
choose rare Beauty which is like so
crazy to think about we should do a vlog
you doing a full video that's the thing
Kylie doesn't even have foundations she
doesn't have like a full yes she does
foundation I'm pretty sure she has
concealer I mean now her website's down
of course oh wait no it's shut up it's
back she has concealer but she does not
have Foundation let's go let's go uh
face
blush bronzer highlights setting powder
um it's not like but like where's
concealer
you know and I know they're in this like
rebuilding phase so it's maybe not fair
to compare but like I definitely think
Kylie Cosmetics definitely dropped the
ball in a major way they were like you
know really on the cusp The Cutting Edge
of everything and then they just kept
doing the same thing and like didn't
evolve with trends
like that cut crease green eyeshadow
look is like not what people are into
anymore it's very much like the
Charlotte Tilbury rare Beauty like glow
shiny like dewy look and honestly I
wouldn't even know how to do that with
Kylie Cosmetics they just like kept
doing like Grinch collabs yeah but that
also could be Cody you know and whatever
yeah
things they need to check off their list
so they are in competition no they are
you're totally right even though I I
don't even think it's a competition
right now because rare beauty is supreme
no but don't count out the Kylie no I
won't and I'm sure I know they're in
this rebuilding phase even though it's
been taking like a hella long time
um and I hope that she's she's like
always been on The Cutting Edge of like
trendy makeup so I don't know how her
makeup brand doesn't reflect that like
at all
yeah
they they definitely need to like Step
It Up Cody's like kind of [__] it up
and like dropping the ball with the
Kardashian Brands like kkw Beauty was
like reformulating literally never came
back it didn't no I thought it came back
recently I don't think so kkwbeauty.com
it's like not loading right so it's like
what the [__] are they doing they spent
two billion dollars on those Brands and
and what I don't know
so that's a conversation worth having
and I feel like actually if I wasn't
doing this for a job I feel like I could
actually do a really good job working at
Cody in like strategy for these Brands
like well we use strategy me
like they need to go with the times like
it's so dated like for me for sure but
like how so specifics okay so Kylie
needs to like drop this like very
Jeffree Star
like um aesthetic it's very like
colorful and pigmented and I think even
when when that was the vibe I don't
think the formulas were that great
and so she really needs to like evolve a
little bit in terms of like what the
makeup trends are right now which is
like more glowy more dewy less full
coverage more fluffy eyebrows and
neutral tones
um and actually kkw Beauty was doing
that when they were in
stock but it was like a little honestly
a little too before the trends and
people have said that like the cake
everyone was like falling over Kylie
Cosmetics like real makeup experts know
like the kkw beauty formulas were the
best like so good but like
everyone was like the packaging wasn't
great and everyone was like obsessed
with Kylie at the time that they were
like not noticing kkw Beauty yeah so I
don't I don't know what honestly how the
two brands are gonna exist if they are
they should really
Cody should should
merge them
yeah but like what about people like me
who who like still to have coverage on
their face and don't want all of a
sudden like want to be looking like you
know the end of a doorknob okay shiny
shiny I feel like you have like a really
big misconception of what like the the
current trend is it's definitely more
natural but it's still like hella full
coverage
for real like I know you think like rare
beauty is like a DOT on your face no I
have I like the rare beauty products
that I use but I use them in the way
that I use Kylie stuff like I look like
but I like that's what that's what
everyone does
most people aren't like wearing no
makeup it's just like it's a lot of
makeup to look like you're wearing less
makeup that's like the the trends right
now got it I don't take Trends with my
face okay I don't do Trends with my face
I do what looks best for your girl a
hundred percent
and I'm not alone but I'm also not
everyone
so by the way back to my original point
about the Selena fans here I just feel
like they are really toxic no they need
a life they need a job they need a hobby
these people have too much time on their
hands to evaluate every video compare it
to the other one
just like get off the internet these are
like the fans that like bullied Haley
Bieber into doing an interview like
these are the fans that jelly like these
are those people and honestly like
Selena engaging with them and like
agreeing with their yeah Haley's coming
for me like really is like feeding the
the farm animals which you're not
supposed to do and I think it makes it
makes them even more empowered to keep
going and that's what's happening now
with Kylie they really need to stop no
and also like if if Haley and Kylie ever
are shading Selena intentionally like
I'm not gonna believe that that's what
they're doing because like it's like the
boy who cried wolf no and it's like let
me see it if I ever like I'm uh maybe
they would and I'll take a look and see
if that's what they're doing no I'm just
gonna assume that the Jelena stands are
reading into something because that's
what they're always doing Selena's been
like kind of going rogue on social media
recently yeah
I think these comments you know being
like this victim me victim are in line
with her going rogue on social media
yeah just like take the phone away yeah
yeah yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
Mean Girls drama the Mean Girls Stars
original Stars may not return return for
the new movie over disrespectful money
offer so original Plastics Lindsay Lohan
Rachel McAdams Amanda Seyfried and Lacey
Chabert have all agreed to return for
the new Mean Girls musical movie but
talks have stalled over Paramount's
disrespectful money offer the stars of
the original 2004 classic have remained
friends throughout the years and were
willing to return for the film which is
bringing the Broadway musical version of
Mean Girls to streamer Paramount plus
quote the production Source says
Paramount Pictures doesn't want to pay
the girls what they are worth all four
girls are willing to come back but
Powerman has not been respectful of what
they are worth uh page six is told that
Rachel McAdams who played Regina George
was initially offered a larger part than
the other a larger sum to play
um a part in the movie than the others
but the deal had not been signed off and
as of now all negotiations are stalled
Tina Fey who both wrote the movie and
musical is reprising her role as math
teacher Miss norbury she has reportedly
signed a seven-figure deal for her
acting role she's also writing and
producing the movie while the girlies
were said to be offered a fraction of
that
I mean it's so interesting because I
think if they want to
negotiate well they should really all be
negotiating like as a team even though
like why would Amanda Seyfried and Lacey
Chabert get to say like in this current
you know climate get the same
pay pay it's actually crazy when you
think about like how that film launched
really launched Amanda Seyfried Rachel
McAdams Lindsay Lohan was already a
start and she went on after that to be
like just as big of a star as everyone
else and the Glacier Bear kind of got
left behind like she's out here doing
Hallmark she's a queen in Hallmark she's
a queen I'm just saying like she's a
queen of Paul Mark and Rachel McAdams is
the queen of the Oscars you know yeah I
mean interesting honestly
sure you would think you wouldn't be
Queen of the Oscars
but I think she has a nice life I think
so too complicated who's happier who's
happier
um
I have so many different thoughts about
this like on the one hand yeah they
should be as a group they kind of do
well deserve the same because also the
three like Lindsay
Amanda Seyfried and Rachel McAdams are
really big stars they deserve roughly
the same and Ergo Lacey should get the
same she shouldn't get and they have the
same role not one of them is like a star
I guess Lindsay Lohan technically but
it's unclear if they would be their
original characters they might just be
like cameos in the background like a nod
to the original film which kind of makes
me depressed but also seeing them as
their original characters would make me
depressed like I don't want to see
Regina George as as like
you know what I would like the
superintendent like I think it would be
cool if it's their kids
but then it's still the focus is on them
and I think the Mean Girls musical is
just the story the same story like we
have Janice and again we have Katie
it's not oh you're right you're not
writing a new movie oh you're right
you're right they're just gonna like
play people in the background which is
just gonna make me feel old and sad for
real like even though it's nice that
they want to be on board I actually
think like
it's a little it would be a little weird
let me say how I could see it going that
way but I actually really trust Tina Fey
like oh first she doesn't put out [__]
you know she's not putting out crap
Tina Fey and um
Mr Duvall to play their original parts
because like that's a no-brainer you
could be a teacher forever but
the girls don't really fit into the
story and I feel like trying to make
them fit would be a little distracting
and a little sad when there's like the
new we have the new crop we have Renee
rap is playing Regina George oh is she
in the movie Renee rap yes she's in the
movie we announced the cast
um
a while ago we have Andrew rice who's
playing Katie Herron
uh oh a loyal uh alulie cravalho played
Moana is playing Janice Ian and jaquel
Spivey will play Damien I think it's so
like interesting and sad that actually
Park
is not in it from she plays um
in Emily in Paris the friend I forget
her name the friend who sings yeah she
got she blew up because she was in Mean
Girls on Broadway she's like an amazing
singing voice
what I have a fun fact but continue wait
so but she's not in the film who did she
play on Broadway can you Google that for
me I'll Google it you know I got it I
got him already what's your fun fact my
fun fact is that Aaron Samuels is going
to be played by Jeremiah from the summer
I turn pretty oh that's good Perfect
cast Okay Jeremiah
the one that's the one oh Conrad Conrad
sorry yeah yeah okay so love that and a
lot of people were wanting him to be
cast in it ends with us like he's people
really love him I think they're really
attracted to him yes so I love that they
got him for this she played Gretchen
Wieners yeah she was amazing and yeah
and she blew up I know she's not with
Emily in Paris but I would love if she
would return but I guess not she would
well you know what I don't see a casting
here for Gretchen so it's up in the air
Jerry's still out also she has an
amazing singing voice and this is a
musical yeah so I love that Renee Rapp
is still being Regina she's like turned
into one of my favorite from strangers
to lovers to enemies
um
love that I love her in sex lives of
college girls like how cool she gets to
work on a show like with Mindy Kaling
and Tina Fey I feel like that's the
dream for like an actress like if
somebody said to me like what if you
could be in any TV show like what would
you like I would want it to be a Mindy
Kaling production or a Tina Fey
production like they're always
successful they're always actually funny
and then it's like iconic yeah
gorgeous
garages so who knows what will happen
with this I don't think I don't think
the original cast members being in it
will make or break it honestly I would
like not at all but how much do you
think they deserve and also knowing it's
just going to be a cameo not you know a
whole ass role I don't know like what
the market is like I don't know what
cameos get paid but like a million
dollars so Tina Fey got seven figures to
act in it could be a million could be
nine million she's also the writer of
the original film it's like she owns the
franchise yeah but I do think like the
way that they worded this I think she's
getting paid separately for that because
she reportedly has a seven figure deal
for her acting role Dash she's also
writing and producing the movie which is
like other money yeah well she's in the
whole movie She's a main character these
girls would probably just be cameos so
if they're getting a fraction of her
acting that's simple math they will
probably work one or two days and she'd
probably work a month but they think
they deserve more at being the originals
and there are the names that they are
all right so maybe it's not gonna work
out and you know what I don't think
it'll affect it in a way that you know
another in another franchise like a
major person not returning would affect
it you know oh yeah because they won't
have major roles regardless yeah I don't
honestly it would be cool to see them
all get back together but like I don't
really care because I want to see the
musical I actually never saw it on
Broadway and I heard it was amazing
um so I want to see the musical just
like period And I don't think that'll
change whether the four of them are in
it yeah but I also could be think it
could be like a no hard feelings thing
like Rachel McAdams is like listen I
don't get out of bed for less than a
million dollars
um maybe if you can't afford that then
okay then we won't do it like it's not
but it has to be all or nothing
agreed not two of them Lacey Chabert
shows up with Lindsay Lohan and then the
other two don't like no yeah no
but if it's just like a little Cameo
like why do they need like a huge payday
if it's just like them like crossing the
street or like they go to the mall and
there's just like these women like
having lunch like
okay I don't need a million dollars for
that like no like do it for the culture
the culture totally okay
our next story some exciting news is it
some exciting news that perchance
happens to be brought to you by our new
sponsor the black tux yes yes it is
because let me tell you I'm excited
you'll find out why it is
not to get all parental but it's time we
had to talk you know the one about that
three-letter word that ends in X you'll
probably experience a few times in your
life
a tux well when you need the tux the
best place to go and get one is the
black tux and by the way I could attest
this because me and Ben did it because
Ben I feel like Ben has had one talks
like since our wedding and it's just
like we tried to make it work like it
doesn't fit anymore you know the black
tux it makes it super easy to get on
Trend top quality guaranteed to fit
tuxes without ever leaving your house so
what you're saying charity is a fabric I
knew you were gonna say that yes it's
top quality fabric that's all you need
to know here's how it works you will
take the black tux fit quiz you'll pick
the style you want to rock and boom your
trucks will be delivered to your door 10
days before the day that you actually
need it it's plenty of time to try it on
make sure that it wears well
and if the fit is not quite right say
hello to the black tux fit guarantee
order a better size within a day or two
of receiving the less than great fitting
one and they'll send another one right
away at no extra cost if you'd prefer an
in-store experience the blacktalk says
showrooms across the country their
expert fit stylist will help you find
the perfect style tux or suit and make
sure it fits just right so me and bed
did this we took his measurements we got
the fit right on the first try we were
really shook Ben was definitely
skeptical
um it looked great we went for like a
more classic look I know a lot of people
love to like experiment and do like
crazy and that's great we're well not me
Ben wanted to do something crazy but I'm
like no we're getting something classic
when we go to weddings when we go to
whenever you need to talks it's always
just like black tie so we got something
really traditional it was really
beautiful it was made really nice and I
just really cannot stress how the fit
was like
fitting rent or buy the black tux is the
best place to go when you need a tuxedo
for a wedding or a special night and
right now when you go to
theblacktucks.com toast and use code
toast you'll save 20 off your order
that's
t-h-e-b-l-a-c-k-t-u-x.com slash toast
code toast to save twenty dollars the
blacktalks.com toast that code is toast
thank you turdy you're welcome our next
story you know who's going to need a
nice tuck soon boom
Phoenix Baron Hilton room yeah Paris
Hilton is introducing the world to her
baby boy and revealing the name that
she's given him on her iHeartRadio
podcast this is Paris the new mom
revealed her baby boy's name which is
Phoenix
his name is Phoenix and then his whole
name is Phoenix Baron Hilton Maximilian
room
um everyone was like tagging me like
Claudia you were right what did I say
um okay that's kind of rude because I
feel like it was me who said it's gonna
be a city like I think I thought it
would be a city and I thought it was
going to be like no I actually think I
said that no I said it because I was
talking about that movie money hype the
show Money heister named after City so
then I just started you know Denver
honestly like
uh Denver is a very warm guest like yeah
also said it was going to be a name that
was like a real name something that's
like you could actually conceive of not
just a bunch of letters put together
um and Phoenix is like dorites baby boys
Phoenix no it's like it's not like a
super common name but it is a name it's
not like a new word that celebrity made
up and it's like it's a name Detroit if
you're looking at baby name lists like
it would come up yeah it's a name that's
like a real name also a city like we hit
all the points of what she was looking
for of course my ultimate prediction was
Maximilian
um maybe the next one I guess there's no
City Max
no now it's like that's clear what she's
doing it's like a theme and I like that
it's also a p Phoenix in Paris like it's
cute I like it a lot and it's also it
was surprisingly normal yeah so this is
what she said about it she explained
that she thought of the name 10 years
ago sharing the story while reading an
excerpt from her upcoming Memoir Paris
so there's this is like a little you
know um teaser Russian nesting doll of
paris's promos on her podcast she read
an excerpt from her Memoir about her
baby's name saying quote if all goes
well by the time you read this Carter
and I will have a baby boy we plan to
name him Phoenix a name that I decided
on years ago when I was searching cities
countries and states on a map looking
for something to go with Paris and
London Phoenix has a few good pop
culture reference points but more
importantly it's the bird that Flames
out and then Rises From the Ashes to fly
again I want my son to grow up knowing
that disaster and Triumph go around and
come around throughout our lives and
that this should give us great hope for
the future gorgeous she also explained
that his middle name Baron is a tribute
to her late grandfather who was always
her Mentor Baron Hilton
love it's a very prestigious Phoenix
Baron Hilton room it's a it's a long
it's a royal name it sounds I like it
but it's also modern it's also very
Paris and it's also very Hilton and I
guess room as well yeah no it really it
has it all I think this is a great I
feel satiated
satiated I like that she gave us an
explanation because if I'd seen Phoenix
I would have just been like oh it's a
cool name but yes a Phoenix Rising From
the Ashes yes Paris tell us more I
really do I love that that metaphor
about a phoenix I really I think it's
beautiful I really do and I think it's a
very apropos in life and I really love
it who has that song Phoenix
gun rise like Phoenix I have no idea let
them see you right
hey hey hey you know it sounds like
a train Olivia Holt I thought Sabrina
Carpet no way I was gonna know that no
no but I was singing Sabrina Carpenter
it's a good song check it out I think
that's what uh inspired Paris check it
out are you ready for our fifth and
final story
yes
Giselle bunchen has transformed for her
first Vogue cover since Tom Brady
divorce Vogue Italia but she once again
American Vogue not getting the scoop for
you know this the Great American
football star's wife but okay right and
they could have had like a garage issue
with her instead she's on the cover of
vogatalia looking edgy which isn't my
favorite it's like the worst word to
describe like if you ever if I ever came
to the room be like would you like this
happening you said yeah it's edgy I
would burn it immediately no like her
hair is dyed red and I can be the first
to say it doesn't look good because I am
a redhead but it's like bright red she
has red thin eyebrows oh red lips and a
red dress honestly she looks like a
fashion clown
yeah she also doesn't look like herself
you know no she doesn't like she's a
gorgeous woman and they just and I get
that she's a model and you're supposed
to like you know be just like a muse in
this blank canvas but when you become a
model who's also like a superstar and
you get known for being Giselle not just
being a model like you want to lean into
that look and also the Vogue Italia it
all seems so Random to me if it had been
like Vogue Brazil okay I would have
loved that you know yeah but I don't
know it just feels random yeah there is
one photo in the shoot where she's not
being edgy fashion model doll Muse where
she's being Gisele she's wearing like a
Dolce dress and her hair is her hair
color
um and she this should been the cover
shot but that's beautiful it's natural
it's sun kissed it's Brazilian it's also
fashion but like if this were like like
she should have been on the cover of
American Vogue like by the beach beachy
waves yeah gorgeousness Giselle in my
own words love
Giselle life is not a game
no that's not my favorite no but it's
like football no I get it no I don't
think you got it let me think hold on
let me think hold on like
Giselle
touchdown America or something like
hold on I'm really I'm tired just like
give me a second Giselle
I don't know
stand up in the comments what should the
subtitle have been yeah if we had a few
more minutes we could think of something
like Giselle running into the end zone
yeah or like something about starting
fresh yeah but like in a sports
reference you know yeah
new season or something turning the
other cleat
okay that's like a little too direct you
know okay okay
um something about a new season like a
new season of sports you know
yeah what do they say about it
they say it's a new season you know
that's what they say Giselle has her
Monday nights back
um it's actually probably like a really
good point and Tuesdays Thursdays and
Sundays right Giselle getting her week
back
instead she's on the cover of vogatalia
in an interview that um isn't Italian
and she's looking edgy dotting it all
red and Maison Valentino look complete
with matching nails and fiery red hair
and lips
and a string of other photos that you
can check out for yourself she also just
went viral I don't know if you saw this
video of her dancing like a traditional
Brazilian dance and like this crop top
and low waist pants no sickening
sickening did she go viral for being
sickening yeah love that for her yeah
and it's just kind of like the year of
Gisele I think yeah but this photo just
doesn't sum that up for me because she
looks like any model who could be on the
cover who's just being like a Model A
model a chameleon a chameleon like a
blank canvas a mannequin yeah but like
is it about this Mason Valentino dress
or is it about Giselle it is supposed to
be about Gisele because the dress is not
dressing enough for me it ain't dressing
it ain't balsamic no and honestly the
other pictures from the shoot are like
so much more interesting even the edgy
ones right but the one they chose for
the cover is not covering is what you're
saying yeah it's just I like you know
beautiful things what can I say you're
kind of crazy like that foreign
so those are the past five you
definitely need to know all but the last
if I'm being honest
um no but we had fun with it and that's
what we do here we're not okay we're not
like you know the news you need to know
okay after five I said it I'll admit it
but we're having fun we're having fun
and the show's not over because it's
dear toasters time our weekly advice
segment usually happens on Wednesdays
but yesterday was kind of crazy
um where you can write in and get advice
from your girls about anything that's
going on in your life it's always
Anonymous so the email is deertoesters
gmail.com we've got three great
submissions today and I'm I'm ready to
dive in are you yeah let's do a 30.
hello gen Z's big sister and La turd
over the past year I've gotten into
reading thanks to you hoes I recently
started posting my book reviews on my
Instagram stories on my latest review I
received a DM from a friend saying she
thought she just bought the book and is
so excited to start reading but here's
my dilemma there's a baby girl that dies
in the book and she has the same name as
my friend's daughter
it's a somewhat common name but not the
usual suspects like Sarah or Emily I
know it'll definitely catch her
attention I know if I were reading a
book and there was a child with my
daughter's name who died it would really
affect me in a negative way should I
tell her this beforehand or am I being
too sensitive is it worth ruining a book
she just paid money for the death is
pretty Monumental to the story I
appreciate your help in advance
sincerely illiterate girls girl don't
tell Ben oh my God that's a really
tricky one I know it that actually
happens to me sometimes where people are
like would I like this book and I know
there's something in the book that will
trigger this person just based on and
I'll say no right but that um you could
say like if it was an event that
happened that's you know would be
personal to that person's life you could
give a like a little bit of a warning be
like I don't know if this would be right
for you just you know given everything
that you've gone through but this is
different because that happens but it's
just like spooky and eerie and who wants
to read that right
I don't know
is your name like Sarah she said she
said it's pretty common but not like
really common like Rachel Sarah Emily
it's not like one but it's not like a
random like euciferous you know yeah
yeah right
you know
um
but you don't want to spoil the book
I know and she bought it already
I honestly don't know what to tell you I
feel like it's okay
yeah it's spooky Yuki but it's not
triggering you know yeah yeah it's just
spookyoki but it's not like something
that she can't handle because of
something that she like it's not what um
what I was thinking it was going to be
which has been like she's been through
something similar like
in which case I always issue a trigger
warning if it's a book that like someone
of course but I I think you just I think
you just leave it this one out yeah I
agree
all right next up
hey my girls I adore you and listening
to the toast is the highlight of my day
today my boyfriend who I've been dating
for about six months told me I'd gained
a quote shitload of weight since we
started dating after looking at an old
photo of me he then proceeded to tell me
he didn't want to be with someone who
was just getting fatter and fatter
how would you proceed I could admit I
put on a few pounds in the last six
months but anyone if anyone knows I know
I don't need him to berate me for one of
my biggest insecurities sincerely a
toaster who loves her brownies I'm just
shook because it sounds like based on
like your question how would you proceed
that this man is still alive
and that's just unacceptable because he
should be dead in a ditch you know and I
would have happily been the one to help
bury this this lard this [__] ass
white and literally no world is this
okay you absolutely have to worry
especially the part where because
sometimes men can be stupid so him
saying like oh you've gained weight like
okay it wasn't it wasn't an observation
it was like a insult the second half of
I don't want to be with someone who
keeps gaining more and more then goodbye
right and to be honest someone who's
like so aware and like turned on and off
by weight like obviously he has a mental
illness yeah and that's so nice and that
wouldn't even notice a few pounds like
it's so not someone you want to be with
long term because life is long no and
like if you want to have babies oh my
God fluctuate and even if you don't want
to have babies like things happen like
you get depressed you lose weight you
gain weight you you know things happen
I've never experienced a more clear deer
toasters in my life six months goodbye
yeah it's not even that long term of a
relationship like goodbye you're you'd
be better off being alone than being
with somebody so miserable and quite
frankly unwell
goodbye good day sir I said good day sir
all right last one hey Jax and Claude
I'm a gen Z toaster here I did not
though find you guys on Tick Tock I
found you guys through Kenzie Elizabeth
and the snatchler the snatchler this is
so interesting and I chose it because I
think it'll spawn an interesting
discussion and I want to hear what
people have to say in the comments okay
so I'm currently a sophomore in college
I'm 20 years old and my parents are
really against credit cards I have a job
in steady income and I'm not in a
financial situation where I really need
one but I realize credit score is
objectively important as you get older
which means I should prepare now
I'm in a long-term relationship with a
guy who's very smart financially he has
a great credit score and he thinks that
I need to start building my credit I see
where he's coming from and I honestly
agree I'm leaning right now towards
getting one just to use strictly for gas
to build my credit the only issue is
that the card will deliver to my home
they don't deliver to my address at
school and I don't feel like
um
and I did not feel like telling my
parents about the credit card do I have
a conversation or do I try and go home
and snag it from the mail before they
see it sincerely a toaster who is
sheltered and just needs to mature
financially so I thought this was really
interesting because obviously like
you're an adult and getting a credit
card is not crazy at all and like either
just tell your parents or go sneak it
like you don't oh you're you can fly on
your own but I thought it was really
interesting like really random like
obscure kind of specific things that you
grew up like not being allowed to do
that like you grew up and realized like
oh it's totally normal like everyone
does that you know yes
um so having a credit card it's not like
demons anything no but I didn't have a
credit card I had my own debit card
I didn't have a credit card until like
well into my 20s yeah I got my first
credit card at
22 or 23. I've been but I felt like I
was delayed in doing that no I remember
like I even when I was living on my own
and I was paying rent and I didn't have
a credit card yet and I don't remember
what oh you know what I got one when tpg
came on the bread so that's what I was
gonna say about that Sapphire one and I
was like you know what I do need a
credit card now because I'm paying
everything on a debit card but for a
while honestly I wasn't ready for a
credit card because like I would like
just
run out of money at the end of the month
and I feel like if I had a credit card
like I would have spent money that I
didn't have it sounds like this toaster
is pretty fiscally responsible and she
has the boyfriend who's fiscally
responsible but you kind of can get
carried away with a credit card and it's
a lot of responsibility and I understand
why your parents might be like you don't
need one because it's just like just go
and you want to build credit of course
but like you're only 20 like you'll get
there I didn't have a credit card till I
guess I was 24 25 and I have a good
credit now I'm 30. so
I kind of see where they're coming from
I wouldn't worry so much about my credit
at 20 years old
okay to be honest like you can get the
credit card or not get the credit card I
think you can make an argument for both
I think getting your credit card is
totally fine as long as you're not
racking up debt you're paying your bills
you're making sure there's no interest
you're paying it in full like
you're fine
but I did want to know like what obscure
things like you as a child were like not
forbidden but like your family just
didn't do that like when you grew up you
realized like oh that's just like a my
family thing you know what I mean yeah I
feel like in our house we literally
never not that we were in a lab but we
just like we're not taking Tylenol we're
an Advil ibuprofen house and like even
now to this day like I know it's the
same thing kind of but like Tylenol suss
I don't know I have questions about oh
and it doesn't [__] work yeah right I
have my suspicions about Tylenol yeah me
too Advil works
and Tylenol doesn't but no I'm still
hung up in the credit card thing because
you know what I think back to it and
like a couple girls that I know I'm not
gonna name names who are very
responsible people I know who you're
talking about
and who had good solid jobs like
salaried yeah like a couple people I
know racked up some serious credit card
debt yeah it was like a problem for them
in their early 20s because you get
carried away you do and like
you can't you shouldn't spend money that
you don't have so why do you need a
credit card unless you intend on doing
that like why can't you just be debit
like she is she wants to build credit
why
why do you want to buy a house she
didn't say so like it's just because her
boyfriend's telling her to do that and
like I feel like he's saddling you with
kind of a lot
and what if he's not going to be like
around so like you know and things just
kind of can spiral yeah things can
spiral like I feel like it's really
important to preach the importance of
like Financial Health and so Brian's
always saying like don't do not get into
the points and credit game if you are
not financially healthy like if you are
in debt it is not for you yet yeah and
there was like a while even I was
working and I was like paying my own
rent but I was not ready for a credit
card same and I went out having dinners
that I couldn't pay for yeah and I was
even I was financially healthy at the
time but I don't think I was mature
enough to really understand the
responsibility of having access to debt
yeah I think for a while you got to live
with that debit card the money that you
have is the money that you spend there
is no in between yeah racking it up you
pay it immediately like I kind of see
where your parents are coming from the
only thing is this girl she didn't say
should I get a credit card she said
should I tell my parents or not that's
what I'm saying so I just want I want to
answer her question but I also think
it's important that we stress like to be
careful with the credit card when you're
young
um but I think she should tell her
parents one she clearly cares what they
think and you shouldn't ever do
something that you that you shouldn't be
doing something that you feel is so
wrong so if you feel like this is what's
right for you want to build credit make
the argument let them know you're an
adult and this is what you're doing but
also like in the off chance that you
know you do find yourself in a bad spot
with it like it's better that they know
that you had instead of in few years
being like Mom Dad I need help I didn't
listen to you and I need your help yeah
no you're 100 right and also like you're
not doing anything wrong or bad so like
there's no need to lie yeah I agree just
make your case you feel so certain that
a credit card is the next step for you
then explain it away now I really chose
this because I want people to pop in the
comments and let let me know like what
is a thing you just didn't do in your
house that like you had an aversion to
as you grew up and then you realize like
oh like no this is normal like everyone
uses this thing like for this girl it
was clearly credit cards yeah for us it
was Tylenol
for Lola from Confessions of a Teenage
Drama Queen it was microwaves it was
microwaves
I'm trying to think you have any others
no it was really Advil
um and it's that's I don't know why this
is like so ingrained in my memory oh
also tampons you know like we grew up in
a house where it was like you know I
wasn't forbidden but it was like you
know tampons just like always go with a
pad and then the older we got like we
all just decided to use tampons we cut a
couple of us found ourselves in some
sticky situations where you needed a
tampon right and then eventually like we
transitioned to tampons but I think
that's actually pretty common because of
TSS and like a lot of like the chemicals
in I don't think that's actually like a
crazy thing that was in our house and I
think that like when you first get your
period like you should wear pads first
as long as you can but I remember I was
on a teen tour and we were doing an
overnight in the desert where like I
mean that's just hard whether you're
using a pad or a tampon but like
uh it was time for a tampon for your
girl yeah I remember the first time I
needed tampon too
where what was the situation I think I
was in Israel and you know Israelites I
would say Israel too oh no way yeah my
teen tour we stopped in the desert
Israeli tampons don't have applicators
I don't know if that's just Israeli I
think like a lot of foreign countries
they're they're also like there are
American ones that don't have
applicators right so it's just like this
they're also American ones that do it's
a piece of cotton wrapped in cellophane
and you just gotta like come easy raw
dog it's like maybe now after having had
my period for 15 years I could do use
one of those and like but to use it
maybe first that's not what I use like
my friends on the trip had tampons so
someone floated me one right and that
gave them a cigarette
it's like prison
um so that was dear toaster thank you to
everyone who wrote in again that email
is deertoesters gmail.com we'll be back
next Wednesday with that and we're back
next week oh no it's not Friday is it oh
my not me like hopelessly no and it's
been a short week hmm I really thought
it was Friday Dan well I'll see you guys
tomorrow then thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the Monday
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to do every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available to practice every
podcast we found out Spotify
gorgeous Thursday and we'll see you
tomorrow for the best day of the week
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
see you then bye love ya bye